I I'm interested in your your comments
on how the brain science has really
advanced in the last 20 or 30 years and
and and on coming to Mastery of new
areas i' I've heard it said that you
know if you really just kind of carve
out the time and focus if in fact you
decided that say 2024 is going to be the
year that you're really going to come to
a deeper understanding of AI and you're
going to read a lot about it you're
going to talk with a lot of people about
it you're going to listen to podcasts
that engage in it um then you can really
achieve a lot in a year but it does need
you know in a sense concentrated Focus
given the bombardment that's happening
around us with so much stimulus given
the inevitable instinct to multitask
what do we know now about concentration
and focus and about cognitive load how
how best we come to Mastery of a new
area so fascinating in fact it was just
in the last six months actually that I
read stolen focus and it is such a
masterful piece of writing that sort of
lays out not just technology today and
that Relentless pace of information
coming at us non-stop but also about the
fact that this has actually been a
decades long experiment that we've been
conducting on ourselves and on the Next
Generation uh potentially without
knowing what the full consequences are
cognitive science has taught us a lot
about how to regain that Focus certainly
one of the things uh to give hope is
that it can
regained even though it does take that
that deliber and that purposefulness it
certainly doesn't happen by accident and
if anything the systems that have been
eroding at our ability to maintain
attention and to go deep into an idea
like you like you said like AI or
anything else uh those things are
systematically put in place and if we do
not deliberately go about saying I'm
going to change the structures in my
life I'm going to take the phone out of
my bedroom at night and make sure I
carve out that time for my sleep or for
my ability to listen and be present with
another human being and not be
distracted by my notifications or
whatever it happens to
be there is a lot of changes possible
for the human brain to regain that
ability and I think that in terms of
answering your question uh I think that
being able to say we know for
instance that when we listen to
something
we absorb some of it and when we see we
absorb but actually one of the most
profound ways to really form
understanding is then to in fact do the
thing that we're doing right now and is
to to speak and to talk with each other
eing Houser's uh curve of forgetting
which is a uh if you like it's like a
sort of reverse exponential curve it
starts real high you know I remember
everything for the next two three
minutes and then it drops off rapidly as
you hit half an hour and then a day and
then a week and then a month that curve
of forgetting can be disrupted by us
engaging in deep and purposeful
conversation around here's what I'm
learning let me try and explain to you
what I think this means and how it
coheres with my understanding does that
make sense to you and I think it was the
physicist Richard feeman who said you do
not understand something truly until you
can explain it simply and what I love
about that is it captures the fact that
communication is not just a mechanism
for conveying thought communication is a
mechanism for
constructing thought it's part of the
reason why uh despite being quote
unquote in the wrong generation for this
I still love to handwrite my notes for
everything because I'm convinced
something different is happening in my
brain when I pick up a pen and I can
maintain a light of focus for 5 10 15 20
minutes that definitely will not happen
if I'm just on the C on the keyboard
yeah what about um growth mindset and an
attitude towards learning and a
confidence that you can come to Mastery
of the
new growth mindset Carol dxw work in
this in particular has gotten a lot of
attention in recent times within
education circles and it's one of those
things that is I think quite polarizing
because so much of it particularly from
an educated standpoint you know for the
for the uninitiated growth mindsets
about the idea that rather than our our
intelligence or our understanding being
fixed that you are just artistic people
they are just the artistic people and
that's fixed or musical or mathematical
and no change is really possible once
you're wired that way versus a growth
mindset where we view that
transformation as something that's not
only possible it's actually something
which is necessary as we go through our
lives as human beings you can see why
this idea is inherently attractive to an
educator because if we're not coming
into this business to help people change
and grow then what are we even here for
but at the same time there are tough
realities and I'll speak about a couple
of them just to so that I'm not talking
in platitudes there are tough realities
in how particularly young people don't
just come to learning ready to learn
there are plenty of obstacles to them
and challenges to their their different
baselines that it's certainly can look
as though there are some people and
they're the ones who are going to do
mathematics extension 2 and get a a band
E4 and then there's everyone else who
just don't even bother
trying the reason why that can be such a
a powerful thing to believe and to say
growth mindset sounds nice but I just
don't really know if it's
true is because and let's just use that
as an example mathematics extension 2 is
the most advanced level of mathematics
you can study in a New South Wales high
school and it's it's tough uh it's so
tough that I myself when I was at school
I looked at and I thought you know what
I don't think I do this maybe I didn't
even think about it yeah it's just there
you go and um that's that makes you
normal Mark that makes you normal I've
had the opportunity to counsel hundreds
and thousands of students who are at the
cusp of making that decision should I
take on extension two or not and I'll
sit down with that student I'll have a
look at their academic transcript up to
that point I'll have a look at the work
they've done what the rest of their
pattern of study might look like in year
12 and I might say to someone you know
what you're capable of this you
are however over the next 12 months with
the goals that you have the things you
want to juggle perhaps this is someone
who wants to complete their uh you know
gold certificate for Duke of enra or
they've just become a school leader or
they are busy working or they're a
part-time carer for a l loved one at
home I would say you know what this is
not for you at this exact moment in time
I could be frustrated about the the
nature of uh our education system and
the kind of Relentless pace of it and
that it moves forward without you
whether you like it or not but it is at
least for now a reality so I'll say
extension 2 might not be for you at this
moment in time but don't give up and
then I'll tell them the story of how I
myself didn't do extension 2 in year 12
and then I went and did a mathematics
degree at University and rather
invalidated all of that there is always
an opportunity for me it was when I
entered University even though it was
obviously a very difficult and
challenging experience for me my mother
passed away in the middle of my first
year of tertiary studies and that was
obviously painful and difficult but at
the same time and I find this really
difficult to explain actually to people
CU grief is such a strange thing there
was a sense of relief not just to know
my mom was no longer are battling lung
cancer as she had for 3 years in a very
traumatic way but that as a family we
could kind of exhale and say all right
we're never going to uh
leave our our mom behind and our love
for her but we can move forward and what
that's going to look like for me is
engaging very deeply throwing myself
into uh and you kind of learning that
for the last three years as a part-time
career myself I hadn't been able to do
so
that's what growth mindset looks like to
me it's it's not I don't think a a
Disney like anyone can be anything they
like if they just believe hard enough I
think reality is a bit sharper and more
rigorous than that but at the same time
it's not falling off on the other side
of the horse and saying there are just
some people who just can't I think
that's a mistake and I love that my
whole job is to show that's actually
that there's a much brighter future than
that the future of the planet uh is
being built in our schools today but our
schools are challenged at the moment all
around the world there are chronic
teaching
shortages there's no Silver Bullet to
that but what's the pitch to someone to
become a teacher what are the rewards of
teaching sell the
profession I'm smiling because I'm
thinking back to my first year of work
which was I mean the first year of
full-time work for anyone regardless a
profession is a tough one because
because you are on such a steep learning
curve and I remember in my first uh my
first month actually I was catching up
with a friend uh I was sitting beside
him at church and everything sort of
finished up and turned to me and he said
hey you you've been working for about uh
you know a month now how are things
going and I said I'm
exhausted I am cognitively taxed beyond
what I even thought was possible but I'm
I'm loving it I I really enjoy what I'm
able to do and I I know that that I'm in
the right place yeah and he looked back
to me he said by the way he said I give
you about three more weeks and I I then
had to give him the pitch that in some
ways you asked me about I'm thinking of
um Daniel pink and his work on
motivation he talks about the fact that
there are some kinds of work you can
motivate people to do them just by
remunerating them effectively more you
pay them the better the harder they'll
work but then there are many other kinds
of work particularly where creativity
and cognitive engagement are really
important where the pay is important
important to the point that you um don't
have to worry about it anymore but after
that more pay doesn't make you better
actually can sometimes get in the way
what really does matter well his answer
and I found this to be so true of my
work in
education are autonomy Mastery and
purpose autonomy you've got to have some
sense of control and self-direction you
can make choices that are genuine in how
you do what you do and I love that as a
teacher I get handed a
syllabus but I can draft experiences for
students that are as broad as my
imagination can come up with and give
that to students as a way for them to to
develop autonomy Mastery there has to be
some proc progression and learning for
myself that I'm getting better at this
and I've got a sense of ah I look back
and myself years ago or terrifyingly I
look literally back at myself from 10
years ago when I started videoing my own
classroom lessons for the first time
there's a there's a thing for anyone
who's out there and would like a real
hit to their self-esteem record yourself
doing your daily work for 10 years and
then look back at what you used to be
like and think wow I can't believe I
ever did it like that but I can see the
change I can see the development of of
Mastery and then lastly purpose there
has to
be a reason that MO motivates you to get
up in the morning and push through the
difficult times and say this is making a
difference for people whether it's
abstractly if your work is is very
distant from the people you get to
interact with or if it's the students in
front of me in the classroom there's got
to be a why that pushes me forward so
those three things those are my pitch
and I discover contrary to my friend who
gave me three weeks I discover more and
more reasons to align me and to give me
Rich purpose and and and motivation
every day that I continue we should
record that and make that available to
Departments of Education around the
country as they look to recruit but but
your story about uh people in the first
year I I think I would never been more
tired in my career than I was at the end
of my first year as a school teacher
it's absolutely exhausting I think there
is an argument that says we don't look
after traine teachers well enough
particularly through their PRACK
programs and when they're training in
schools and we don't look after um
introductory te teachers well enough
that we almost throw them in the deep
end and almost abandon them to the most
complex classes often in the most
demanding schools do do you think we
need to be better at mentoring and
coaching and and helping those who are
starting to put down deep roots in the
profession without a doubt there is so
much that we can do better in those
spaces that you just mentioned and I
think back to my own say for example as
a student teacher and then when I
entered the workforce fully uh I would
say that I survived D my student teacher
placements rather in spite of what most
of the system around me was giving me in
terms of support uh and I'm thankful
that I did I had people to lean on and
people cry to but again that wasn't
because the system that I now am a part
of did a really good job of saying you
need these things you need these kinds
of mentoring and support in
relationships to to help you to sustain
you and when I became a full-time
teacher for the first time uh by virtue
of the fact that the second job which I
then spent a significant amount of time
in as a teacher that I ever got was at
my old school and I think my old
teachers most of whom were still at the
school looked at me and thought Oh look
here's young Edward that's right and
they went out of their way I think by
virtue of the fact that they still saw
12-year-old me somewhere hiding inside
that early career teacher and so they
they very consciously
uh said hey look we know you have no
idea what you're doing with this let me
show you or let me give you another
perspective or here's a resource here's
the questions that I ask when I'm trying
to do the same thing they might help you
but I came to realize uh you know maybe
after teaching for three or four years
that that
was I don't usually like to use the word
luck but it certainly was not by some
Grand Design of the school that I was at
or or the broader Department that that
happened it was mostly coincidental I'm
very thankful for it but we need to do
better and a lot of the work that I
engage with right now is about creating
those mentoring and coaching
relationships and it's interesting you
know teaching isn't the same as
mentoring and coaching it's a very
different Dynamic and so for an
experienced teacher to learn to do that
for someone who was earlier on in the
journey there's a whole new set of
skills I guess this comes back to your
earlier question about do adults and do
children learn differently I think it's
a different kind of learning that does
require different skills on the part of
the mentor or coach and we're just at
the beginning I think as a system of
getting better at that Eddie we've often
thought that you know teachers you know
they hold all the knowledge and all the
wisdom they have all the
answers is that how you see good
teachers
operating Mark I think this is what I
used to imagine that a model teacher
looked like I remember early in my
teaching career one of my mentors was a
teacher named Bob and uh I I hope he's
listening out there because this is a
story which I hope warms his heart Bob
was the kind of teacher who I would seek
out when I Was preparing a lesson and I
just could not understand what I was
doing wrong with a particular problem
there was a question and I was just
getting the wrong answer over and over
again sometimes I would get 10 different
answers they'd all be wrong and at we
send I would say Bob please help me and
he'd say what is it come over ready let
me have a look and I would show him a
question and within seconds he would not
hesitate he would not take a moment to
rub his chin wistfully and think let me
let me Ponder he would instantly reply
ah I recognize this question this is in
the 1995 HSC was question seven I
believe a real Corker kids had trouble
with this one and I would just Not only
would I still be confused from the
question I couldn't solve I was just
flumed by his ability to in an
encyclopedic way know every question
that seemed to have ever been written by
human beings about every topic and he
could do this it wasn't just a one off
every time I came to Bob he would know
the answers and I just thought to myself
wow if only I could be a teacher like
Bob and so I I set out in those first
few years to read
develop my own encyclopedia as it were
and to say hopefully I'll get to a point
where one day a student will ask me a
question and I'll say ah yes this is
from the yellow Fitzpatrick exercise 15D
and I'd rattle off and answer just as
comly as Bob did and after maybe four or
five years especially after you get to
teach a course a few times I certainly
wasn't there at the end but I'd gotten
along to a point where I felt confident
where students were asking me questions
and I really truly knew that the answers
and I came to a point where I realized
okay I have fit that portrait of what I
thought a great teacher was but but
actually I I don't think I'm helping my
students learn necessarily I I think I'm
getting in their way because what I was
doing was being so preoccupied with how
clever I was and how well I knew the
answer that actually my attention had
been completely shifted away from the
student to myself and that is a critical
error for a teacher to make I realize
that a great teacher isn't so much
someone who knows all the answers but is
someone who knows how to ask the right
questions and now having been on this
journey for a little while now my
students know when they ask me a
question if it's a question that is
supposed to just have a number as an
answer or or a yes or a no yes you're on
the right track no you're on on the
wrong track even the students around the
person who ask the question will say
come on you know Mr W is not going to
give you the answer on that because I've
trained them I will ask anywhere between
three and 400 questions a day the better
I've gotten as a teacher the fewer
answers I've given because I think it's
really hard it's a absolutely a craft to
be able to design a good question that
doesn't spoil where the students at in
their own understanding but gives them
just enough of a nudge to elicit their
own understanding and make progress